ah  so we're gonna play a game that has  something to do a thought I dig that  combo yeah how spicy are we getting  [Music]  I'm scared there's a lot of adrenaline  coursing through okay sushi I don't feel  like eating sushi all right so there's  some avocado sushi that's been placed in  front of us which only means one thing  oh my god  [Music]  I don't love this this is tricky my guy  [Music]  [Laughter]  it's really great seeing your face like  this because that was my face few times  has a feel my heart's beating really  [Music]  yours is I think on the weight now I  [Music]  think I'm good guys burning as it goes  when I was a little sip it was like oh  ah never doing this again  I'm not replying to your emails I'm  already not thrilled about the farts  oops gonna burn enjoy spicy [ __ ] Oh  [Music]  [Music]